government support is in place however
the Prime Minister mistras did earlier
this week in an interview and several
interviews actually say that households
wouldn't have to pay more than 2 500
pounds for their energy bills that was
wrong wasn't it
well that's an average price for an
average household there would be some
household staff because of the size of
their property might pay more there'll
be some that will pay less what is
happening here is that we're
guaranteeing What's called the unit
price of electricity or gas so that then
will have a direct effect on bills we
won't see the really alarming Bill Rises
that I think many of us were braced for
before the government's announcement so
it's an important intervention it's
going to give a lot of certainty to
families and businesses up and down our
country yes bills are rising uh we're
facing world energy price pressures but
this is a really major intervention that
will give a lot of help and support to a
hard-pressed household this this winter
well yes uh thanks for clarifying that
because the Prime Minister did actually
get that wrong saying that people
wouldn't have to pay more than 2 500
some might if they use more energy but
even with the government help Energy
prices are still going to be around
twice what they were last winter and any
gains they've got from the energy
support package will be wiped out
weren't they by Rising inflation and now
Rising mortgage costs as well in the
aftermath of the mini budget
look I I think we have to accept that
there has been some turbulence in the
last few days
um some mortgage products have been
withdrawn and that's really hard for
those affected I think what is important
is that as we move forward into the
winter we create as many circumstances
of uh or to encourage growth as possible
and that's why I think the government
was right to act quickly on Energy
prices it was right to announce its
Ambitions on growth the way that we're
going to get through these challenging
times to pay for our public services to
generate the income that we need as a
country will be to grow the economy and
that's why I think that when you look at
the overall package you look at some of
the changes that we're making uh to uh
incentivize that growth and also some of
the existing taxes on Banks and on our
energy companies that are yielding lots
of revenue for the exchequer you know
the the overall picture I think we'll
see is much more balanced one than
perhaps has been the case over the last
few days
it's interesting you say that the focus
is
it's hard to see how that growth is
going to come when we've got inflation
running at 10 people's mortgages
mortgage costs are going through the
roof with Rising interest rates energy
bills are going up dramatically and now
we've got the the chancellor and the
leveling up secretary hinting a big
spending cuts to come they say we are
going to balance the books and we need
to be prepared for cuts and spending I
mean we're looking at the austerity all
over again aren't we
well we've got an existing uh spending
uh review package that was announced
last year that was for three years
government's going to be working within
that overall package yes I I highly
accept that inflation is having an
effect on us just as it is other
developed economies in the world but I
think the government by signaling that
it's going to stick to that package to
stick to uh that fiscal discipline by
working with the bank working with the
office for Budget responsibility we are
giving the signals to the markets and to
others that we intend to be extremely
rigorous when it comes to bearing down
on a public expenditure now that that
will be developed in the weeks ahead
we've got a whole range of announcements
coming out on uh not just uh uh spending
but also on supply side reforms whether
it's Child Care a big issue for many
families or whether it's Broadband
connectivity all these things actually
add up to an overall package that is
designed to to first of all facilitate
growth in the economy but secondly to
emphasize that the government is
responsible that the very fact we've had
we're having this debate this week the
very fact we're having this sort of
argument this this important argument
about fiscal discipline demonstrates I
think that as a country we're extremely
uh mature when it comes to this sort of
activity and I think the market should
get a lot of reassurance that this
government like its predecessors will be
seeking to balance the books in a
sensible way okay so what does that mean
pensions for example will pensions rise
in line with inflation
well I think the government's been very
clear about the triple lock uh there are
no plans to change that I think it's
right to look at uh you know the The
Wider picture and the chief Secretary of
the treasury's got a job to do he's got
to make sure that all departments are
efficient and as lean as possible I
think we all need to uh get behind him
and work with him to achieve that and
that emphasizes the balanced approach
that we seek to take in the months ahead
so if if pensions look to rise with
inflation because of the triple lock
what about benefits will benefits rise
with inflation
well look again I think that's a really
important issue for for many of us for
many families uh we're looking very
carefully making sure that uh the
poorest and those in greatest need in
our society get the help that they
clearly need through these winter months
I think that once the government is
right to look at the overall package and
to take care as to uh how our public
spending is allocated I I I I don't
think that it's right to say that uh uh
you know automatically this means that
Universal Credit will not rise uh as
expected I think we just need to work
these things through in the next few
weeks and provides much certainty as
possible to households and businesses
across the country
so you can't confirm that benefits will
rise within inflation in the 2019
Manifesto that the conservative party
were all about leveling up weren't they
and now we've got a mini budget that
gives a tax cut for the super rich the
scrapping of the 45p raids we've got
this possible below rise below inflation
rise in benefits for the poorest and
cuts that could be on the levels that
we've last seen in the days of austerity
has leveling up gone out of the window
certainly not it's a central part of the
government's mission to make sure that
particularly parts of the country that
have historically been left behind are
given opportunities through investment
through the sort of infrastructure
changes that I think will unlock growth
in those areas is when you look at the
overall package that was announced last
week there is as much in terms of tax
take as there is tax breaks so uh we've
been talking about the 45p rate that's a
very small element of a package that's
still by the way contains major hikes on
corporation tax for the banks the oil
and gas Levy the sort of Revenue raising
that the opposition has has been calling
for but seems to choose to ignore by
failing to look at the detail of what
the government has actually set out in
its fiscal package